I'D LIKE TO GET THIS A COMMITTEE
HEARING STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WE HAVE.
BOTH THE SIDES OF THE AYE
REPRESENTED IN SO WELL.
SEVERAL AYE CASKEY WHICH LIKE TO
PRESENT THANK YOU. FOR BEING
HERE YEAH GOOD GOOD GOOD EVENING
AND WERE BACK ON S. B. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT THAT LIKE TO THINK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
UP WHAT WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS --
IN IN PRINT WE WAS A COMBINATION
OF WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF
ARE.
NOW WITH OUR SEVENTY TWO HOUR
RULE WE WANNA MAKE SURE THINGS
GET DONE --
QUICKLY SO THE BILL THAT'S
BEFORE USE BASICALLY LIMITED
PLASTIC BEVERAGE AYE CONTAINERS
WE'VE REMOVED OF THE OPPOSITION
FROM THEY THAT CAN MANUFACTURES
INSTITUTE IN THE CLASS.
PACKAGING INSTITUTE IT ALSO THE
BILL BEFORE YOU DOES NOT INCLUDE
ANY OTHER CONTAINERS THAT ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO THE CRV.
I'M WE'VE STRENGTHENED THE
ENFORCEMENT BY MAKING VIOLATIONS
UP PER DAY PENALTY TRULY
INCENTIVIZING THE INDUSTRY TO
ACHIEVE OR EXCEED THESE MINIMUM
CONTENT.
US STANDARDS THE MINIMUM 20%
CONTACT REQUIREMENT FOR PAT IS
COMPLETELY FEASIBLE --
AS A STAFF REPORT POINTS OUT
THREE STATISTICS SAY THAT WE USE
FOR THE TH FORTY THOUSAND TONS
ARE RECYCLED PET IN.
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
TO ACHIEVE A 20% WE NEED ROUGHLY
EIGHTY THOUSAND TONS.
OF OF PAT AND THE STATE
GENERATES ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND TONS IN SALES OF
PET ANNUALLY SO --
ASSUMING ZERO INCREASES IN
RECYCLING AND AND ZERO INCREASES
IN PROCESSING --
AT CAPACITY WE ARE RECYCLING AND
PROCESSING ENOUGH TO SUPPORT A
45% MINIMUM CONTACT LEVEL LEVEL.
FURTHER IN EUROPE COCA COLA HAS
COMMITTEE INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF RECYCLED.
AND RENEWABLE MATERIAL IN THEIR
PLASTIC BOTTLES FROM 25% 240% BY
TWENTY TWENTY SO NOT THAT WE
HAVE TO BE LIKE THE EUROPEANS
BUT I THINK IT DID IT ADDRESSES
THE FEASIBILITY.
LET ME BE A CLEAR ON THE INTENT
HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE SAME.
WE WANT TO SUPPORT AN INCREASE
RECYCLING MARKETS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THAT I HAVE A
COUPLE WITNESSES WHO ARE WELL
KNOWN TO THE COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK MURRAY
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE --
THEY'RE A BEVERAGE CONTAINERS.
PLASTIC BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THAT
ARE ALREADY FAR EXCEEDING THE
PROPOSED 20%.
THEIR BEVERAGE CONTAINERS IN
CALIFORNIA LITERATE 0% RECYCLED
CONTENT WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE THE
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY IS ALREADY SO
REPORTING.
THE VOLUME OF RECYCLE CONTENT TO
CAL RECYCLE SO WE ALREADY HAVE
THAT INFORMATION.
ANTICIPATING THE LATEST
OPPOSITION THE LATEST POINT FROM
THE OPPOSITION THERE MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH RECYCLE CONTENT IN
CALIFORNIA TO MEET THE 20% --
THAT IS NOT TRUE THERE IS.
ENOUGH FOOD GRADE RECYCLED PET
RECYCLE P. ET BEING GENERATED
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TODAY TO
MEET AS THE AUTHOR POINTED OUT.
A 45% RECYCLED CONTENT THAT
MATERIAL RIGHT NOW IS GOING TO
FOOD GRADE UP PRODUCE PACKAGING
--
THAT.
LOCAL CONTENT IS AVAILABLE AND
THAT FOOD GET GREAT RECYCLE
CONTENT MATERIAL IS CHEAPER
RIGHT NOW THEN THE VIRGIN
MATERIAL.
THIS MEASURE WILL CREATE UP A
LOGICAL PROGRESSION BOMB JUST
LIKE WE DID WITH GLASS TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO WE SET UP A 25%
AND THEN 35% RECYCLED CONTENT
REQUIREMENT. FOR THE GLASS
CONTAINER TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO
NOW TODAY THE GLASS INDUSTRY IS
EXCEEDING THAT WITH 50% RECYCLED
CONTENT FOR GLASS BOTTLES MADE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE GLASS THAT'S BEING.
SOLD TO THOSE CLASS MANUFACTURES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
CHEAPER THAN THE GLASS THAT IS
BEING PURCHASED BY MANUFACTURES
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA SO THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO TRUTH TO THE
NOTION.
THAT THIS RECYCLED CONTENT
MANDATE IS GOING TO INCREASE THE
COST FOR THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY.
VERSION AYE VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR AND AND AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND I'LL TRY TO
BE QUICK BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE ANTICIPATING DINNER --
I REPRESENT CPR SEE IF THE
CALIFORNIA PLASTIC RECYCLING
COALITION IT MAKES UP NOW FIVE
IT WAS SIX OF THE LARGEST PEOPLE
WHO ARE FOR PROPER ASSESSORS AND
RE KLEBER'S.
THEY TAKE THE BOTTLE AND THEY
MAKE IT INTO A NEW PRODUCT TO BE
MADE INTO ANOTHER BOTTLE SO THAT
THE CLOSE OF THE LOOP.
I WILL TELL YOU WITHOUT MINIMUM
CONTENT AND I'VE BEEN DOING
LOBBYING FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS
YOU'LL LOSE THE OTHER FIVE THEY
CANNOT MAKE IT.
THEY NEED TO HAVE THEY'VE MADE
IT MILLIONS IN INVESTMENTS IN
MANY OF YOUR DISTRICTS.
INCLUDING MISTER FLOORS.
AND THEY HAVE SPENT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS PUTTING TOGETHER THEIR
PROCESSING PLACES TO ACTUALLY DO
THIS WORK THAT MAKES BOTTLES
INTO ANOTHER PRODUCT TO BE
RECYCLED R. P. T. BOTTLE.
THEY CAN'T TAKE THE LOSSES THAT
HAVE CONTINUOUSLY WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS USING VIRGIN --
VIRGIN PLASTIC FROM CHINA SO WE
URGE IN AYE --
I WILL JUST END WITH SAYING THAT
MOST THE PEOPLE WHO ARE OPPOSING
THIS BILL --
HAVE ALREADY SAID IN EUROPE THEY
CAN DO FIFTY BY.
TWENTY TWENTY AND SOME OF THEM
CAN DO FIFTY OR FORTY BY THIS
YEAR IN SUMMER DOING A HUNDRED
SO TO ASK THEM TO DO 20% IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHEN ALL OF THIS IS JUST GOING
TO GO INTO LANDFILLS AND WATER
IS BEYOND COMPREHENSION AYE
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
HOMES CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PREY ON BEHALF
OF REPUBLIC SERVICES.
IBM AS IS POINTED OUT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS --
THE POLICIES IN CHINA HAVE CUT
OFF THAT MARKETPLACE IN THERE.
FOR THE MARKET FOR THIS KIND OF
FORCE OF PLASTIC AS WELL AS
OTHER RECYCLED MATERIAL HAS
DROPPED.
PRECIPITOUSLY.
OF THIS MEASURE --
WILL BRING BACK SOME OF THAT
DEMAND I WILL POINT OUT THAT OUR
COMPANY IS LOSING ABOUT A
MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH IN OUR
RECYCLING BUSINESS.
AND THIS WOULD BE A AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO BRING THAT MARKET
BACK WE'D URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
JEFFREY FANNED OUT OF EVERY
PLANET IN SUPPORT.
GEN A PRICE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO CREDIT WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
JEAN AROUND BEHALF WASTE
MANAGEMENT WE SUPPORT I'D
NATIONAL SORT IS UPENDED
EVERYTHING WE NEED TO DO THIS
THANK YOU.
I CAROLINA'S HIGHER ANTI ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO THE SOLID WASTE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA THE
COMPUTER CAN.
CONSUMER PRODUCTS SEARCH
ACCOUNTS ON SUPPORTING THE
QUEUE.
TENTATIVE OUT ON ON BEHALF OF
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION HEAL THE
BAY AND THE REST OF THE CLEAN
SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME.
FOR THE CHAIRMAN EMERITUS ET AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FREDRICKA
MCGEE ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION.
AND TODAY UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
REMAINING AND OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO INCREASE RECYCLED
CONTENT THE NUMBER THAT WAS
PROVIDED ABOUT COKE IS ACTUALLY
TWENTY THIRTY AND NOT. TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THEIR 50% OUR GOALS
--
OUR INDUSTRY HAS BEEN A LEADER
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS ALLOWED
FOR THE RE USE OF RECYCLED
CONTENT.
NOT ONLY FOR PLASTIC BUT
ALUMINUM FOR GLASS UMP THE
RECYCLED MATERIALS ARE FEET
SACH.
FOR IT NOT JUST NEW BEVERAGES
BUT ALL --
CUTS THE PACKAGES AND CONSUMER
PRODUCTS --
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE BEVERAGE AND IT OFF TO ON ON
INCREASING ARE RECYCLED CONTENT.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT THE
ARBITRARY NUMBER THAT WAS JUST
RECENTLY PUT INTO ESPY'S AT SIX
ONE SIXTY EIGHT IS NOT BASED ON
ANY DATA OR A REAL RESEARCH --
IT COULD CREATE SIGNIFICANT
MARKET DISTORTION AND RECYCLED
PET CHAIN AND ADDITIONALLY
DISRUPT THE FLOW OF RECYCLED PET
FOR THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
I UNDERSTAND WILL WELL BEYOND
THE DEADLINE DATE FOR DOING
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL AND TRUST
ME WE HAVE TRIED REPEATEDLY WITH
NO SUCCESS TO HAVE MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SENATOR
AND A STAFF --
BECAUSE AUTHOR HAS DECLINED TO
HAVE THIS DIALOGUE WE'RE HOPING
THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD
CONSIDER HOLDING THE BILL TODAY.
WHEN THE BILL WAS GUIDED AND
AMENDED IN JANUARY TO BE THE
MANDATORY MINIMUM CONTENT
LANGUAGE IMPLEMENTATION DATE WAS
JANUARY TWENTY ONE WITH CAO
RECYCLE SETTING THAT DAY --
IN THE LAST THREE LEGISLATIVE
DAYS THAT DATE HAS MOVED TO
JANUARY TWENTIETH ATTENUATE
TWENTY TWENTY WITH A 20% --
LEVEL.
THE ABRUPT CHANGE HAS WITHOUT
ANY DISCUSSIONS WITH ANY OF THE
OTHER --
OPPONENTS OPPOSE STAKEHOLDERS
ARE WITH A BEVERAGE INDUSTRY ARM
OR WITH THE CONTAINER
MANUFACTURERS TO DETERMINE IF
THIS DATE COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED
IS IS REALLY UNREASONABLE --
BASED ON TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
DATA FROM CARRY CYCLE 20% OF THE
CRV PET BOTTLES TOPIC BOTTLES
WITH EQUAL A HUNDRED AND TEN
BILLION POUNDS --
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
NUMBER WOULD GO UP TO A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN MILLION POUNDS.
NATIONWIDE ACCORDING TO THE
CONTAINER RECYCLING ACTIVITY
REPORT THAT WAS RELEASED IN
OCTOBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN NATIONWIDE THERE IS
ONLY THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION.
POUNDS OF FOOD GRADE.
BOB OUR P. T. THAT IS ONE THIRD
CALIFORNIA WOULD CONSUME A THIRD
OF THE NATIONAL RPG THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR FOOD GRADE AND I
KNOW THE PROPONENTS SAY A WE
HAVE PLENTY.
BUT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN.
OUR PET THAT IS NOT FOOD GRADE
THERE'S PLENTY OF NON FOOD GRADE
OUR PET AVAILABLE ABOUT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION TIMES OF OF OF
THAT AND ACCOUNTS OF THAT
ACTUALLY.
BUT IT IS IT IS A LOT EXTRA WORK
THAT A RECLAIMER HAS TO GO
THROUGH TO GET TO A FOOD GRADE
LEVEL THAT'S ACCEPTABLE FOR THE
FDA TO ALLOW US TO RE USE IN
FOOD GREAT PRODUCTS.
I CALIFORNIA LEE KRAMER SAY THEY
CAN MEET THIS GOAL BUT THEY THEY
HAVE NOT DONE ANY STEPS TO SURE
ASSURE US THAT THE FDA
REQUIREMENTS COULD BE COMPLIED
WITH -- THE
ARBITRARY MAIN MANDATE CAN
CAUSE.
A SPIKE IN THE PRICES AND
THERE'S NOTHING THAT WOULD
PREVENT THEM FROM SETTING THE
PRICE IT ANY ABOUT THEY WANT
WITH THIS MANDATE THERE.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THEY GET THE
ADDITIONAL [inaudible]
BUDGET A PMDEEP PAYMENTS AND SO
IT SEEMS TO US THAT THERE'S AN
UNJUST ENRICHMENT HERE --
WE HAVE ONE OF OUR SMALL
BOTTLERS IN THE MODESTO AREA
BARNEY BROTHERS WHO SENT A
LETTER TO THE ASSEMBLY YESTERDAY
THAT SAYS THE LIFE.
CYCLE OF THEIR BEVERAGES IS FROM
FIVE TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS AND
IT WOULD BE ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THEIR COMPANY TO PULL THE
UNEXPIRED.
PRODUCTS EXISTING PRODUCTS FROM
THE SHELVES ON BY THE DEADLINE
THAT'S PROPOSED IN TWENTY YOU
KNOW FOR THE JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINE.
THERE'S CONTRADICTORY LANGUAGE
THAT TALKS ABOUT THE THEIR EACH
BOTTLE HAS TO HAVE 20%.
OR THERE'S A MONTHLY AVERAGE
IT'S NOT CLEAR EVEN FROM THE
EXACT LANGUAGE OF THE BILL.
ANOTHER MIGHT BIG ISSUE IS MANY
OF THE BOTTLERS IN CALIFORNIA
DON'T MAKE THEIR OWN CONTAINERS
AND THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO
CERTIFY UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY.
THAT THEY HAVE THAT AMOUNT IN
THEIR CONTAINERS WHEN THEY ARE
NOT THE ONES THAT PRODUCE IT
THEY HAVE CONTRACTS WITH A
DIFFERENT COMPANY BUT THEY ARE
NOT THE ONE THAT PRODUCE IT.
AND AGAIN THE PENALTIES ARE NOT
CLEAR IN THE BILL THE SECTION
THAT PREVIOUSLY REFERRED --
TO RESOURCE PUBLIC RESOURCES CO
ONE FOUR FIVE NINE ONE SET DAILY
FINES AND MAXIMUM THAT LANGUAGE
HAS BEEN STRUCK FROM THE BILL SO
WE'RE ON CLEAR IF IT'S A HUNDRED
DOLLARS A DAY AT THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY.
IF IT'S PER VIOLATION IF IT'S
PER STORE IF BIG BASS ON EACH
BOTTLE SO NONE OF THAT IS CLEAR
FROM THESE GET FROM THE LANGUAGE
OF THE BILL. FOR THESE REASONS
AND MANY MORE WERE ASKING FOR
YOU KNOW.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME.
FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DON
KEPT HIM HALF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED THE REASONS
STATED THE CURE.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
KOREA BOSS SOME HALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT --
PAUL GUYS FOR BEING LATE BUT
JUST ONE GET THAT ON RECORD
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE COMING
FORWARD --
TO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU ARMCHAIR --
I CENTER EIGHT JUST ABOUT A
COUPLE QUESTIONS WE THIS WILL
DECIDE ADDRESS A QUESTION WAS
ASKED ABOUT.
OF THE 20% IS JUST MESSING IT
MENTION IN PASSING WHAT WOULD
HAVE THAT NUMBER COME FROM WILL
CAME FROM THE HOUSE CYCLE WERE.
FROM THE PLASTIC INDUSTRY HIS
THEY'VE BEEN YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR HAS HAD A PANEL OF OF
OF PLAYERS TOGETHER FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS TRYING TO COME UP WITH
AN UPGRADE ON THE RECYCLING
PROGRAM.
DID THIS BILL ORIGINATED AS AND
I'VE EXTEND THE PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE I WATCHED
OVER THE LAST TWO OR THREE YEARS
ALL THE PARTIES COME IN AND ONE
PARTY WOULD MOVE HERE ONE PARTY
WILL MOVE HERE [inaudible]
A PLASTIC.
CROWD HAS HAS SAID IS THAT THEY
WANT A BENCHMARK THEY WANT 20%
I'VE AVOIDED THAT MUCH.
THROUGHOUT MOST OF THE TIME WITH
THIS IN ALLOWED CAL RECYCLE WHEN
IT WAS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE LAST
TIME I SAID I WAS ELECTED
EXPERTS --
PUT A BENCHMARK AYE IN BUT AS
WE'VE SKINNY THAT THIS BILL HIVE
ACQUIESCE TO WHAT PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN ASKING FOR ON THE ON THE
20% THIS NUMBER'S BEEN.
BATTERED AROUND [inaudible] FOR
THREE YEARS.
SO IT IT IT ISN'T FROM A STUDY
OR THE UC'S ARE ANYTHING LIKE
THAT THAT WE WERE HARD NUMBER
THAT'S COMPANIES THIS IS JUST
SOMETHING THAT.
WELL GEE WE'D LIKE TO SEE A
NUMBER LIKE BECAUSE I KNOW I'VE
HEARD THE NUMBERS FLOATING
AROUND I'VE HEARD TEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY AND WE CREDIT FOR A YEAR.
ESPECIALLY SINCE FLOSSING YOUR
TESTIFYING THAT CAME UP I'M JUST
CURIOUS AS TO WHERE THAT OTHER
CAME FROM AND AND THEN AND I
DON'T THE SURE IF THERE WAS A
SOFT A STUDY BUT I KNOW IT WAS
THE INDUSTRY WAS COMING UP.
THE RECYCLING INDUSTRY WAS
COMING UP WITH THAT NUMBER RIGHT
IN THE BUT NOT BUT NOBODY IN ON
THE OTHER SIDE THE MANUFACTURING
SIDE THAT THAT THAT MEMBERS
COUNCIL THEY HAVEN'T SAID HEY WE
THINK WE CAN LIVE WITH.
AND A NUMBER SO THIS. FOR MY
WORDS NOT YOURS BUT THIS SEEMS A
LITTLE BIT ARBITRARY IN THE
SENSE THAT.
INDUSTRY HAS TESTIFIED THAT THEY
HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN ABLE TO TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION IN TERMS
OF OF THAT PART OF IT SO AT THAT
DOES CONCERN ME A LITTLE BIT.
BUT I I'LL I'LL MOVE ON BRIT
BRIEFLY WHAT ABOUT THE ARM.
THE BEVERAGE CANS ALSO MENTIONED
--
THAT THE CONTENT AVERAGE IT IF
IT IS THAT BIG IN THE BILL
BECAUSE I I COULDN'T REALLY.
FIND A HEART OF A FIRM NUMBER
THERE IS IT PER BOTTLE IS IT.
CAN WE AVERAGED IT WHAT WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR HERE.
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL IS IS
AVERAGE --
SO IT IS AN AVERAGE AMOUNT
CURRENTLY THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY
IS ALREADY REPORTING TO CAL
RECYCLE THE VOLUME OF VIRGIN AND
THE VOLUME OF RECYCLED
THE THIS BILL ASSUMES THAT SAME
MEASURE ON SO WE KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE THE PEPSI COLA IS
ALREADY DOING 21% ON AVERAGE WE
KNOW THAT NESTLE IS ALREADY
DOING 42%.
ON AVERAGE THIS BILL IS
INCORPORATING THAT SAME CONCEPT
WHICH IS AN EXISTING LAW OF A
BEVERAGE --
THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY REPORTING.
AND THE CAL RECYCLE CERTIFYING
BASED ON AB SO SO TO CLARIFY FOR
FROM MY MY MY SMALL BRAIN HERE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW.
AN INDUSTRY AVERAGE THEN COMPANY
OUR COMPANY COMPANY AB AVERAGE
OKAY COMPANY AS A EACH COMPANY
HAS TO COMPLY SO IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF IT'S MONTHLY WEEKLY
THAT WE COME ANNUALLY NOW OR
JUST THE REPORT WHICH IS AN
ANNUAL PORT.
AYE I'M ASSUMING.
REPORTING AS IT IS WITH CLASS
THE REPORTING IS IN THE BILL IS
MONTHLY IS MONTHLY A SAME
ASSIDUOUS CURRENTLY WE'RE GOING
OKAY THAT'S WHAT I WAS.
TRYING TO GET AT SO THAT IT THAT
ANSWERS THAT QUESTION ABOUT COST
CONTAINMENT SENATOR WE DON'T.
WE DO WE HAVE TO COST
CONTAINMENT THE BILL SEEMS TO BE
MISSING FROM THIS THAT THAT
THERE'S NO.
GET I WOULD DISCUSS GUYS A LIMIT
HERE IS THAT IS THAT THE FOR THE
CASE HERE YES I GUESS I DON'T I
DIDN'T BUILT ANY COST
CONTAINMENT SAID NO THE PREMIER
OBJECTIVE HERE.
IS TO RECYCLE OUR PLASTIC
MATERIAL OBSOLETE GOD SO THAT'S
SO THAT'S THAT WE HAVE FIFTEEN
MONTHS BEFORE THIS GOES LIVE SO
THE WHOLE WORLD'S GOING TO KNOW.
WHEN THEY BOTH A LEGISLATURE?
MOVES MOVED TO SPELL I'M
COMMITTED IF THERE NEEDS TO BE
CLEAN UP MY COMMITTEE IN THE BAR
ON THE SENATE SIDE IS COMMITTED
TO DOING ANY LEGISLATION IF
THERE'S ANY DOUBT ON WHAT WERE.
A ARE TRYING TO GET TO ACHIEVE
HERE.
WELL WHAT IF THE PRICE WERE
DEAD.
SAY DOT COM BACK TO THAT TWENTY
TWENTY NUMBER THAT YOU
[inaudible]
AS MENTIONED AN IMMINENT LAST
QUESTION BUT YOU EAT WHAT IF THE
PRICE GOT OUT OF CONTROL WERE
HOT WHAT WHAT WHAT THERE'S NO
MECHANISM IN IN HERE FOR THAT SO
IF THE DOUBLED OVERNIGHT ARE YOU
SAYING THAT.
WERE GONNA START BECOMING A NET
IMPORTER OF THOSE ON A MATERIAL
OR THE PRICES WILL WIN COUNTY
THAT I CRAZY WHAT WHAT WE LISTEN
HELL RECYCLE HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO SET.
CHANGE THIS AND THEY WILL
INCLUDE THOSE THAT I'VE COSTS AS
THEY SET THE STAMP IS THE
STANDARDS GOING FOR SO CAL
RECYCLE HAS THE AUTHORITY.
TO MANDATE SOME FORM OF COST
CONTAINMENT IS WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING WELL NO I'M SAYING THAT
WERE WERE SETTING THE FLOOR 20%.
WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY THAT COULD
GO THE TWENTY TO TWENTY IS NOT
DEALING FIVE BUT WHEN IF THEY GO
UP.
AS HE MOVED UP THEY HAVE THEY
WILL INCORPORATE THE COSTS IN
THE ANY FUTURE --
STANDARDS HIM OKAY ARE IN IN THE
LAST POINT WHY DID WE THE BILL
GO FROM MY ME YADDA 20% SOURCE A
NUMBER.
WHY DO WE GO FROM TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY NOW THAT IT
WAS MENTIONED EFORE WE TOOK OUT
GLASS AND WE TOOK OUT ALUMINUM
SO WE WE HAD WHEN WE FOCUSED
ONLY ON PLASTIC AND WE BELIEVE?
INTEREST IS THE TESTIMONY HAS
BEEN THAT.
INDIVIDUAL COMPANIES ARE
REACHING THIS GOAL AND AS THE
STAFF REPORT POINTS OUT WE
RENDER LITTLE CRISIS WITH ALL
THIS BILL THE PLASTIC IN AND
MATERIAL THAT THE NATIONAL
SOARED IS NOT TAKING THE
CHINESE.
ARE MATERIAL IS PACKING NOW AND
WE NEED --
TO INCENTIVIZE THE INDUSTRY TO
START RECYCLING ARE MORE FOR
PLASTIC THAT WE DO IN A REAL
GOOD JOB ON SOME OF IT WE HAVE
TO GET CLEANER PRODUCT AND MORE
PLASTIC.
ARE INVOLVED IN THE STRING.
WELL WELL I APPRECIATE THAT AND
AND LOOK LIKE WE ALL WANT TO GET
AS MUCH.
MATERIAL OUT OF OUR LANDFILLS AS
POSSIBLE I AND I FOR ONE DO I
HAVE A OF A NUMBER OF TWELVE
LANDFILLS IN MY DISTRICT AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
A PUBLIC POLICY AS WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE DRILLING DOWN I
I CAN'T SUPPORT IT IN ITS
CURRENT FORM TODAY I OF THIS TOO
MANY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS I
DON'T LIKE THE MOVEMENT OF THE
DATE I DON'T LIKE.
THE FACT THAT THERE'S NO COST
CONTAINMENT AND THE SKY'S THE
LIMIT IN TERMS OF PRICING I
APPLAUD WORRY HER.
WERE TRYING TO GO UP BUT THAT'S
WHY I WANT TO GET TO THE ROOT OF
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT YOU MAY
BE HERE SENATOR AND ANSWERING
THE QUESTIONS ARE.
THERE ARE.
YOU KNOWN FORMALLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS WERE OUT TO CHIEF HERE.
RUPTURED YOU HERE ACOSTA.
HERE'S MORE WORDS WERE DOING THE
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM ALL ARMS
--
HERE.
ACOSTA HERE PARTLY CHAU.
CHAU HERE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE FLORA.
FLORA HERE LIMON.
MCCARTY MELENDEZ REYES.
REYES HERE STONE [inaudible]
STONE HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SMITH MADE A SECOND IT ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CERNER Y. KOWSKI FOR A PUTTING
FOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL IDEA
[inaudible]
I'M.
MY I KNOW THAT A LOT OF THE
DETAILS COULD BE WORKED OUT
THROUGH THE REGULATIONS FROM CAL
RECYCLE --
AND WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT THE
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION WILL.
RISE TO THE CHALLENGE SO MUCH IS
MADE AND SECONDED DRINK RIGHT --
CENTER WAS ON CLOSE OUT JUST A
NOTE THAT I I DON'T THINK THAT
WE CAN AFFORD TO DELAYED THE
PRIMARY OBJECTIVE OF I SP ONE
SIXTY EIGHT AND THAT IS TO GIVE
THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY.
WOULDN'T NOTICE TODAY THAT IN
FIFTEEN MONTHS WE'RE GOING TO
SAYS WE'RE GOING TO EXPECTED
EVERY BEVERAGE PRODUCER TO IT
THAT WE ARE COUNTING ON TO
SUPPORT THE RECYCLING MARKETS
EQUAL 220%.
OF THE PET PASSED PLASTIC
PACKAGING PACKAGING THAT WE
INTEND THAT THEY INTEND TO SELL
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH THAT AYE
DIVERGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MOTIONS BEEN MADE AND
SECONDED CHAIRS RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
THAT INSECT RIPLEY'S CALDERON.
ITEM TWO SP ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI THE MOTION IS
TO PASS.
MEMBERS WERE OUT TO KILL AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA NO ACOSTA
KNOWN CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON [inaudible]
MCCARTY MELENDEZ [inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE AYE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
AND MEMBERS.
SO WHEN YOU.
THE BILL IS ON CALL.
NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR ROTH
PRESENTING SP ONE TWENTY AND CO
PRESENTING IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
I DON'T.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M OF PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE THIS
EVENING WITH A ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN TO PRESENT THE SENATE
BILL ONE TWO ZERO ONE TWENTY
IT'S A BILL TO ENHANCE
PROTECTIONS FOR A STATES
DESERT'S BY CREATING A REVIEW
PROCESS FOR THE STATE TO ASSESS.
PROPOSALS TO EXPORT DESERT
GROUNDWATER TO OTHER AREAS OF
THE STATE.
I SHOULD --
START BY SAYING THAT I'M
CERTAINLY NOT ONE FOR LAYERING
ON UNNECESSARY BUREAUCRACY IN
PERMITTING PROCESSES KNOW OR IN
MY ACTUALLY KNOWN AS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AROUND HERE AS
EVIDENCED BY MY VOTE RECORD.
BUT I THINK THERE'S AN IMMEDIATE
NEED FOR GREATER STATE OVERSIGHT
OF PROJECTS THAT SEEK TO STATE
TAKE WATER OF THE DESERT AND
SEND IT TO URBAN AREAS.
THAT'S WHY WHEN IT WAS FRANKLY
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THAT
THERE IS THIS PROJECT THAT'S
PROPOSING TO EXTRACT ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER
ANNUALLY FROM BENEATH THE MOJAVE
DESERT.
AND EXPORT THE WATER TO WATER
AGENCIES THEM SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILES AWAY IN WHEN THE AS
POINTED OUT THE UNITED STATES
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY INDICATED THAT
IT CAN ONLY SUSTAIN A MAXIMUM OF
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER
YEAR.
AND THEN WHEN THE PROPONENTS OWN
PROPOSAL REFLECTS A DISCHARGE
RATE OF ABOUT.
FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET PRE
YEARS AGAINST TO RECHARGE RATE
OF ABOUT THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
FEET PRE HERE.
I BEGAN TO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
AND WHEN YOU CONSIDER THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ESSENTIALLY ABDICATED ITS
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LANDS IN THE MOJAVE.
THROUGH WHAT TYPICALLY WOULD
HAVE BEEN A NEPA PROCESS.
I THINK THE STATE HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE OF THE
REVIEW THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED TO TAKE PLACE BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IS COMPLETED BEFORE AUTHORIZING
A PROJECT THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT.
SUCH A FRAGILE ECO.
FURTHERMORE CONSIDERING THE
CONFLICTING ESTIMATES ON THE
AMOUNT OF WATER THAT CAN BE
SUSTAINABLY EXTRACTED.
WELL AS PROVIDED THE KIDDIES THE
PROJECTS APPLICANTS AND OTHER OF
SCIENTISTS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S OWN FIGURES --
FRANKLY IN MY OPINION THE STATE
MUST CONDUCT AN INDEPENDENT
SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS. FOR AND
ALSO TO RESOLVE THE SCIENTIFIC A
CONFLICT THE CONFLICT BETWEEN
SCIENTISTS.
BEFORE ALLOWING THE EXTRACTION
OF WATER FROM THIS --
DESERT TO UPPER.
FOR NOW.
I'M NOT TRYING TO PREVENT THE
PUMPING OF WATER FROM THIS SOCK
FOR HIM TO BE CLEAR ON THAT.
BUT I THINK WE MUST ENSURE THAT
THE SCIENTIFIC REVIEW IS
COMPLETED AND THAT THE SCIENCES
RECONCILED.
IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ABOUT WHETHER
THIS OR ANY SIMILAR EXTRACTION
PROJECT SHOULD MOVE FORWARD.
NOW WE CAN AND WE SHOULD DO IT
QUICKLY.
BUT WE MUST DO IT.
I THINK AT THIS POINT OF I WILL
TURN THE MIKE OVER MICROPHONE
OVER TO MY A CO AUTHOR.
SIMPLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. FOR HER
COMMENTS WITH YOUR PERMISSION
MISTER CHAIR YES PLEASE THANK
YOU ARE THE SENATOR DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB SUMMING UP.
OUR POSITION --
WE ARE FRANKLY US SITTING HERE
AGNOSTIC AS TO HOW MUCH WATER
CAN SAFELY BE DRAWN OUT OF THIS
BASIN BUT GIVEN THAT ARE DESERT
IS VERY PRECIOUS.
AND IT'S NOT COVERED UNDER SIGMA
WE'RE ONLY GOING TO GET THE
CHANCE TO GET THIS RIGHT ONCE WE
KNOW THAT ONCE OP OFFERS ARE
OVERDRAWN THEY DO NOT RECOVER.
AND THIS THIS OP OR FOR IS THE
PRIMARY SOURCE OF WATER FOR ALL
REFERRED ARE.
MOJAVE NATIONAL RESERVE AND LOTS
OF OTHER PROTECTED LANDS SO WE
NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT WE DO.
AND GIVEN THAT THERE IS A
DISPUTE BETWEEN A FEDERAL
AGENCY.
ARM AND THIS FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION AND THE PREVIOUS
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF RECHARGE IN THE BASIN
AND GIVEN THE CHANGING HYDROLOGY
IN THE DISTRICT BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE STATE'S
ROLE IS TO HELP TO RECONCILE
THOSE NUMBERS AND MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER IS DRAWN IS SAFE FOR
THE AREA.
THAT SHOULD BE OUR TOP PRIORITY
--
TIRED THIS BILL I THINK IS A
VERY REASONABLE STEP TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE HAS A ROLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE VOTE AQUIFER
IS NOT OVERDRAWN.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORTS.
CHAIRMAN MARC MURATSUCHI AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS NEIL THE SITE
HERE WITH THE NATIONAL PARKS
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SP ONE
TWENTY A BILL TO PROTECT OUR
CALIFORNIA DESERT.
A PLACE THAT CALIFORNIANS LIVE
IN HOLD DEARLY.
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN NINETEEN AND
PCA IS A LEADING.
NATIONAL INDEPENDENT VOICE FOR
THE PROTECTION OF OUR NATIONAL
PARKS FOR PRESENT AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
WE SEE THE MOJAVE.
THANKSGIVING WE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT AS AN ASSET
WORTHY OF CONTINUED INVESTMENT.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH GENERATIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS TO PROTECT
ICONIC LANDSCAPES.
SUCH AS JOSH TREE AND THAT
VALLEY [inaudible]
AND MOJAVE.
THIS IS PAYING OFF LITERALLY.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE THESE
PROTECTED PARKS GENERATED THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC OUTPUT. FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES CREATED OVER
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED ANNUAL
SUSTAINABLE JOBS.
AND OVER ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN LABOR INCOME.
WILDLIFE SUCH AS BIGHORN SHEEP
KIT FOX AND DESERT TORTOISE HAVE
FOUND REFUGE IN RESTORED
LANDSCAPES.
AND RECREATION OPPORTUNITIES
HAVE BEEN CREATED TO ENHANCE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE MORE THAN TWENTY
THREE MILLION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIANS WITHIN A HALF THE
DRIVE OF THE ASSASSINATIONS.
BUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SEEKS
TO PILLAGE WHAT WE HAVE BUILT UP
OVER GENERATIONS.
DO THE KITTIES PANTHER KIDDIES
GROUNDWATER MINING PROJECT IT
BACKS.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
REQUIRED THIS PROJECT UNDER BOTH
FEDERAL NEPA REVIEW.
BUT THIS REQUIREMENT HAS BEEN
EVENTS RATED BY THE CURRENT
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION AND THE
PROJECT WILL NOW ESCAPE THE
FEDERAL RIVER REVIEW THAT HAS
BEEN REQUIRED SINCE THE PROJECT
WAS FIRST PROPOSED TWENTY YEARS
AGO.
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
REMOVAL OF THE GOAL POST.
COULD THESE WILL NOT BE SUBJECT
TO REVIEW BY FEDERAL SCIENTISTS
AT THE NATIONAL PARK SERVICE.
AND THE U. US GEOLOGICAL SURVEY.
TWO OF OUR NATION'S MOST SITE
RESPECTED SCIENTIFIC
INSTITUTIONS.
THE SCIENTIFIC AGENCIES CAME
CAME TO FIND MUCH DIFFERENT
RECHARGE RATES THAN WHAT THE
PROJECT PROPONENTS CLAIM.
BY THE USGS IS UP FINDINGS THE
PROJECT WITH PUMP UP TO TWENTY
FIVE TIMES MORE WATER.
THAN IT'S RECHARGED.
THERE MUST BE BOUNDARIES TO
POLITICAL EXPEDIENCE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL NEGLIGENCE.
S. B. ONE TWENTY AFFECTIVELY
RESTORES ORDER.
IN SCIENCE BASED DECISION MAKING
THAT WE'VE USED FOR DECADES TO
SUCCESSFULLY MANAGE OUR PUBLIC
LANDS PRIOR TO THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS KIM DELFINO AND I'M
THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM DIRECTOR
WITH DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND
WE REPRESENT ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
A WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY IN THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT WHERE THE
ORGANIZATION THAT SUCCESSFULLY
LISTED THE DESERT TORTOISE AS AN
ENDANGERED SPECIES BACK IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SO WE HAVE
WORKED FOR MANY MANY YEARS IN
THE CALIFORNIA DESERT --
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE KIDDIES
VALLEY IS A VERY SPECIAL PLACE
IT'S LOCATED IN THE MOJAVE SOUTH
OF THE MOJAVE PRESERVE A AND
HISTORIC ROUTE.
SIXTY SIX AND EAST OF TWENTY
NINE PALM PALMS MARINE BASE --
ACCORDING TO INDEPENDENT
SCIENTISTS AND THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE THE AQUIFER THAT THE
KIDDIES CORPORATION PROPOSES TO
MINE.
EXTENDS INTO THE NEWLY CREATED
MOJAVE TRAILS NATIONAL MONUMENT
AND THE MOJAVE NATIONAL PRESERVE
THIS AQUIFER.
SUSTAINS MANY DESERT SPRINGS AND
PLANTS THAT ARE ICONIC THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO ICONIC DESERT
WILDLIFE SPECIES INCLUDING
TORTOISE BIGHORN SHEEP.
MAPI FRINGE TOED LIZARD AND KIDS
BOXES.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE KIDDIES
CORPORATION PROPOSES TO
UNSUSTAINABLY MINE THIS DESERT
AQUIFER BY PUMPING.
FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF
GROUND WATER EVERY FOR FIFTY
YEARS.
THAT SIXTEEN BILLION GALLONS OF
WATER WORTH FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE GALLONS PER SECOND.
THE PROJECT IS UNSUSTAINABLE
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO PUMP MORE
WATER FROM THE AQUIFER THEN IS
REPLACE NATURALLY.
A IN WITHIN THE WATERSHED AND AS
ALREADY NOTED THE ESTIMATES FROM
THE U. U. S. GEOLOGICAL SURVEY
SHOW THAT THE RAIN AND SNOW
WITHIN THE AQUIFER'S WATERSHED
UNIT.
RESTORE IS ONLY BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN THOUSAND ACRE
FEET PER YEAR.
SUPPOSED TO THE FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRE FEET THAT THEY'RE PROPOSING
TO UP PUMP OUT.
A THIS IS SOMEWHERE BETWEEN ONLY
FIVE AND 25% OF WHAT HE'S SAYING
--
THEY'RE GONNA POP.
THE RESULT OF THE UNSUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MINING WILL MEAN
THAT THE WATER TABLE IS GOING TO
DROP IN THIS AREA.
AND THAT WILL DRY UP THE SPRINGS
AND IT ALSO KILL OFF ALL OF THE
TREES AND VEGETATION AND THAT
THE ROOTS STONES THAT GO DOWN
WITH THIS WATER TABLE.
AND THE PROJECT ITSELF SAYS IT'S
GOING TO BE DROPPING THE WATER
TABLE --
THEY'VE ACKNOWLEDGED THIS WE'VE
SEEN THIS KIND OF BROWN WATER
MINING OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN
CALIFORNIA YOU ONLY HAVE TO LOOK
TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO SEE
WHAT THE EFFECTS ARE.
A SEVERELY OVER DRAFTING AN
AQUIFER.
THESE IMPACTS WILL BE MORE
SEVERE WITH IN THE DESERT.
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE THE ANNUAL
RAINFALL IS ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
INCHES PER YEAR.
AND YESTERDAY CALIFORNIA
RELEASED ITS FOURTH CLIMATE
CHANGE ASSESSMENT.
WHICH SAID THAT BASICALLY THE
DESERT IS ONLY GOING TO BECOME
HOTTER AND DRIER WHICH MEANS
THESE TYPES OF WATER SOURCES ARE
ONLY GOING TO BECOME MORE AND
MORE CRITICAL.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE IT
CLEAR OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS THAT THE TIME OF DRAINING
OUR AQUIFER'S UNSUSTAINABLY IS
OVER.
WE JUST PASSED THE SERVICE
GROUND MY SERVICE --
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT.
AND THAT'S WE MUST BE MANAGING
OUR WATER SOURCES MORE
SUSTAINABLY.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY IS
CONSISTENT WITH THAT POLICY IT
WOULD PROTECT OUR DESERT'S AND
PARTICULAR PUBLIC LANDS BY
CREATING A DEFINITIVE PROCESS
BUT STATE TO ASSESS THE
PROPOSALS TO EXPORT DESERT
GROUND. TO OTHER AREAS OF THE
STATE. TO QUOTE SENATOR
FEINSTEIN WHO IS A STAUNCH
OPPONENT TO THIS PROJECT.
PROJECTS LIKE KIDDIES PUT PUBLIC
PROP PRIVATE PROFIT OVER PUBLIC
LANDS BELONG TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND REMEMBER THIS PROJECT IS
ONLY ALIVE RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE OF THE CHANGE IN
ADMINISTRATION AND BECAUSE THE
ONE OF THE LEAD OF
REPRESENTATIVES FOR THE KIDDIES
CORPORATION.
IS NOW CURRENTLY THE NUMBER 2%
OVER AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR.
AND WHO REVERSED THE SOLICITORS
OPINION THAT WAS GOING TO
REQUIRED NEPA ANALYSIS AS PART
OF THE RIGHT OF WAY OVER BLM
LAND THAT THIS OF THE PROJECT
WAS GOING TO HAVE TO OBTAIN.
AS EVERYONE SHALL ANY DIRECT RAP
YEAH I'M I'M LITERALLY IN THE
HOME STRETCH RIGHT NOW.
AS YOU ONE TINY OFFERS A VERY
CLEAR CHOICE YOU SHOULD STAND
WITH CALIFORNIANS AND PROTECT
OUR PUBLIC LANDS OR STAND WITH
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION WHO
VALUES OF PLANS ONLY FOR THEIR
ABILITY TO EARN PROFITS FOR
THEIR FRIENDS AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PILOT
TREAT ON BEHALF OF BUT CHIANG
AND THE COLUSA TRIBES.
IN ADDITION JACOB HERE COULDN'T
BE HERE I'VE TWO SENTENCES TO
READ --
KIDDIES POSES FAR TOO GREAT A
RISK TO THE CALIFORNIA DESERT
WILDLIFE AND THE NEEDY FOR
PEOPLE'S WHOSE CULTURES AND WELL
BEING ARE AN EXTRA BIT EXTRA
CUP.
AND STRICT BLEED LINKED WITH THE
HEALTH OF THE DESERT.
TASKS AND THEREFORE STANDS IN
WHOLEHEARTED OPPOSITION TO THE
MISGUIDED KIDDIES PROJECT AND
CALLS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
PERFORM INDEPENDENT REVIEW OF
THIS PROJECT [inaudible]
PLEASE SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK.
A GOOD EVENING CAO JONES WITH
URKEL CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSION A PRICE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA LEAVE
CONSERVATION VOTERS.
THIS IS A THREE DECADE OLD PET
PROJECT FOR A COUPLE OF RICH
SHAREHOLDERS IS UNNECESSARY IS
COSTLY ENVIRONMENTALLY
DEGRADING.
AND ITS ENERGY INTENSIVE WE ARE
DRIVE OUT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JENNIFER
FEARING ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR FOOD SAFETY.
AND WATER FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
NEEDS TO BE RELIABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE THAT THE KIDDIES
PROJECT AS NEITHER OF THESE
THINGS THE STATE SIMPLY MUST UP
REVIEW AND ASCERTAIN THAT WE ARE
DRY VOTE. ONE OF THE MEN ON A
WITHOUT OF ON CALIFORNIA YOU
STRONG -- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
A WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS IS.
IT GOOD POLICY DOESN'T MEAN UP
PUMPING.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MARK FENCED MAKEUP HALF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON FEDERAL THAT
ALONE THOUGH I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF OF THE KATHLEEN THEY PLANT
SOCIETY AS WELL AS A SOON IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
KIM SHRINER POP THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THINK YOU.
ELENA ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF MOJAVE
DESERT LAND TRUST AND SUPPORT
THINK YOU.
DAVID LAMB FROM I CAME FROM THE
MOJAVE TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE MOJAVE NATIONAL
PRESERVE CONSERVANCY.
THAT VOICE FOUNDATION HISPANIC
ACTORS FOUNDATION THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHECK OF
MOSS ON BEHALF OF THE NATIVE
AMERICAN LAND CONSERVANCY.
WE ARE AN ASSOCIATION OF TRIBES
WHOSE CULTURAL AND RELIGIOUS
SITES WILL BE DECIMATED BY THIS
PROJECT.
WE HAVE BEEN FIGHTING THIS FOR A
LONG TIME AND DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT A FEW TEMPORARY JOBS --
JUSTIFY THE DESTRUCTION OF A
MILLIONS YEAR OLD AQUIFER AND WE
UNFORTUNATELY ARE ASKING
CALIFORNIA TO STEP IN --
TO UNDER THE OBLIGATIONS THE
FOURTH BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO OUR GOVERNMENTS I'M IN
MULTIPLE TREATIES AND
AGREEMENTS.
JERRY MEMBERS NIKITA CRIED WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ERICA MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF
EARTH JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PHOEBE SCENE LEADERSHIP CUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LEE AND
TROUT NO BEHALF OF NEXT GEN IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING NO
FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES THAT OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO GET TO CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE SO SCOTT WHICH A
BEHALF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PIPE TRADES.
FIRST OF ALL WHERE THE WITNESSES
CALLED THIS POLITICAL
EXPEDIENCY.
POLITICAL EXPEDIENCY IS A BILL
THAT WASN'T THAT WAS AMENDED ON
FRIDAY FOUR DAYS AGO.
WHY WASN'T THIS AROUND IN
JANUARY WHY NOT NEXT YEAR THIS
IS A PROJECT HAS BEEN AROUND?
FOR TWENTY YEARS.
AN I TAKE EXCEPTION TO SOME TO
SAYING THAT IT'S FOR A FEW
TEMPORARY JOBS.
THESE ARE JOBS UNION JOBS SIX
THOUSAND UNION JOBS IT WILL MOST
IMPOVERISHED AREAS WITH SOME OF
THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATES
AMONGST OUR MEMBERS IN THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A PROJECT THAT HAS GONE
COMPLETELY THROUGH THE SEQUEL
PROCESS.
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
IT'S FOLLOWED EVERY STEP THAT
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
A PROJECT GO THROUGH.
HAS BEEN CHALLENGED IN COURT
MULTIPLE TIMES AND SUCCEEDED IN
IN MITIGATING IN A MEETING EVERY
ISSUE.
AND NOW AT THE ELEVENTH HOUR
FOLKS WANT TO PULL THE RUG OUT
FROM UNDER THIS PROJECT AND
THREATEN.
IT'S THOUSAND UNION JOBS.
IF THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PROCESS.
LETS HAVE A THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS NEXT YEAR
BRING YOU BACK IN JANUARY.
THERE'S NO REASON TO AMEND IT
FOUR DAYS BEFORE THE END OF
SESSION THREATENING SIX THOUSAND
UNION JOBS WE WOULD URGE
[inaudible]
AND OVER [inaudible]
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
IF THE OPPORTUNITY WITH YOU
TODAY I'M JIM LEACH WITH THE
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
--
WHERE THE LEAD AGENCY THE LEAD
PUBLIC AGENCY ON THE KITTIES
PROJECT?
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL --
WE WERE HERE LAST YEAR ABOUT AB
ONE THOUSAND ROACHES THIS BILLS
PREDECESSOR AND IT WAS A GOT THE
MEN BILL ROLLED OUT LATE IN THE
SESSION --
IT WAS ON SUSPENSE UNTIL FRIDAY
OF LAST WEEK --
WHEN IT EMERGED AND SO
REGRETTABLY WHAT WE HAVE AGAIN
THIS YEAR IS ANOTHER GOT THEM IN
BILL ROLLED OUT THE LAST MINUTE?
THAT I HAD INDICATED HAS ONE
TARGET ONE PROJECT THE KIDDIES
VALLEY WATER CONSERVATION
RECOVERY STORAGE PROJECT.
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
DOES NOT HAVE ANY GROUND WATER.
WE POUR ALL OUR DRINKING WATER
SUPPLY FROM METROPOLITAN.
I ONE OF OUR BOARDS CONTINUING
CONCERNS THE RELIABILITY OF OUR
SUPPLY LONG TERM.
IT'S PROJECTS PLANNED TO BE A
PART OF OUR SUPPLY PORTFOLIO BUT
LOOKING BEYOND OUR SERVICE AREA.
THE WATER WILL ALSO BE PUT TO
BENEFICIAL USE FOR OTHER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIANS IT'S A
SUPPLY WATER THAT WILL OTHERWISE
EVAPORATE.
ON THE DRY LAKE BEDS IN MOJAVE
DESERT.
THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN THROUGH
THE RIGOROUS SEQUEL PROCESS IT
WAS ULTIMATELY CERTIFIED
UNANIMOUSLY BY OUR BOARD.
WE'VE ENJOYING THE COUNTY OF SAN
BERNADINO IN REVIEWING AND
ULTIMATELY APPROVING ALONG WITH
THE COUNTY.
THEIR GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
MONITORING A MITIGATION PLAN.
THAT ENSURES CONTINUOUS
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THE HEALTH
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF THE BASE IN
THE WATER.
PROJECT IS BEEN EXTENSIVELY
LITIGATED APPEALED AND HAS
PREVAILED IN EACH AND EVERY CASE
AN INSTANCE.
IN SPITE OF CAREFULLY FOLLOWING
THE RULES AND PROCESS AS WE NOW
HAVE S. B..
ONE TWENTY WITH THIS ROUND.
I WHICH REQUIREMENT FOR ANOTHER
ROUND OF REVIEWS.
AFTER THE SECRET PARTS OF THE
MET.
IT'S BEEN SAID THAT THERE ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SCIENCE FROM
THE PROJECT HAVE BEEN ANSWERED
THAT CAN ONLY BE ANSWERED IN
ADDITIONAL REVIEW.
SEQUEL WAS FOLLOWED INCOMPLETE
AND WE HAVE TO ASK WHY THESE
ADDITIONAL AGENCIES DIDN'T
PARTICIPATE IN THE ORIGINALLY I
OUR PROCESS.
WE BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE A
CONCERN THAT THE PASSAGE OF SB
ONE TWENTY WILL HAVE THE EFFECT
CHALLENGING THE CREDIBILITY OF
SEQUEL.
US EAGLE REVIEWS IF OPPONENTS
CAN GET ANOTHER BITE AT THE
APPLE WITH THIS KIND OF
LEGISLATION.
THE LAST MINUTE GOTTEN AMEND
APPROACH TO THIS AND OTHER
ISSUES IS IN OUR VIEW AT THE
VERY LEAST NOT APPROPRIATE.
LEGISLATION THE COULD HAVE THIS
KIND OF IMPACT SHOULD GO THROUGH
THE REGULAR OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS NEVER THE LAST.
HERE WE ARE.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN TODAY IS
THAT IT IS F. B. ONE TWENTY
PASSES NEITHER THIS PROJECT NOR
ANY PROJECT SUBJECT TO SEQUEL
WILL BE SAFE FROM AFTER THE FACT
LAST MINUTE INTRUSIONS INTO THE
PROCESS.
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THE SECRET
PROCESS IT WAS APPROVED AND
LITIGATED.
YIELDING RECHARGE WE MONITOR TO
CONTROL BUT THE COUNTY OF SAN
PORTANTINO WAS RESPONSIBLE
AGENCY UNDER THEIR PLAN.
THIS BILL TODAY IS NOT ABOUT
MAKING SURE ALL THE TEES WERE
CROSSED AND I'S WERE DOTTED THIS
IS ABOUT MOVING THE FINISH LINE.
WE URGE TO STOP THIS BILL NOT
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT ON
THIS PROJECT.
BECAUSE THE LONG TERM HARM WE
BELIEVE IT WILL COST TO THE
CREDIBILITY THE IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS AND
FUTURE LAWFUL SEQUEL REVIEWS.
WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT DUNCAN
MCFETRIDGE REPRESENTING KIDDIES
AT LIKE TO YIELD THE BALANCE OF
MY TIME TO LESLIE MOULTON WHO --
PROVIDED THE SEQUINED ALICE'S
AND CAN INFORM THE COMMITTEE ON
JUST TO THE EXTENT OF THE
ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE.
NOT ONLY ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT BUT ON THE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT PLAN AND I
WOULD LIKE TO PUT ONE THING IN
CONTEXT.
THIS PROJECT AS A JACK TO
WITHDRAW FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE
FEET OF WATER A YEAR.
BUT TO PUT IT IN CONTEXT THERE'S
ABOUT THIRTY MILLION ACRE FEET
THAT UNDER LAYS.
THE BASIN THIS WAS DONE IN A
SUSTAINABLE AND RESPONSIBLE
MANNER.
WE URGE YOU KNOW ABOUT.
LESLIE MORTON POST WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE ASSOCIATES
PRESIDENT AND C. E. O. WHEN I
WAS THE PROJECT MANAGER FOR THE
SECRET PROCESS FOR THE KIDDIES
WATER PROJECT.
AND I THINK I JUST WANT TO HIT
ON TWO POINTS AND THEN CERTAINLY
BE AVAILABLE.
FOR ON QUESTION SHOULD YOU HAVE
THEM.
ON THE QUESTION OF PROCESS THAT
HAS BEEN ADDRESS THERE'S A
CONCERN THAT THIS HASN'T GONE
THROUGH A THOROUGH STATE PROCESS
BUT OF COURSE IT DID GO THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT PROCESS.
WHICH TOOK ABOUT FOUR YEARS TO
EXECUTE [inaudible]
A A NUMBER OF AGENCIES FEDERAL
STATE LOCAL REGIONAL WERE
INVITED TO COMMENT DURING THE
SCOPING PERIOD.
OF INCLUDING THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND GAME STATE LANDS
COMMISSION CHOSE NOTTO
PARTICIPATE FISHING GAME DID
SUBMIT A LETTER AND ALSO.
FURTHER SUBMITTED WHEN THEY DID
REVIEW THE DRAFT HE AYE ARE A
COMMENT LETTER.
OF THE BLM THE U. S. B. ARE THE
U. S. G. S. AND THE NATIONAL
PARK SERVICE WERE ALL INVITED.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE SEQUEL
PROCESS AND SOME OF THEM DIDN'T
SOME OF THEM DID NOT --
OVER A HUNDRED SIX INDIVIDUAL
AGENCIES AT THE STATE LOCAL
FEDERAL REGIONAL LEVEL WERE
INVITED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROCESS.
SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
THOROUGHNESS AND PROCESS
INTEGRITY THAT OF COURSE IS
REQUIRED.
UNDER OUR STATE SECRET PROCESS.
AND I DO THINK THAT PROCESS
INTEGRITY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE QUESTION OF
ON THE GROUND WATER RECHARGE --
DEBATE AND DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION AMONG EXPERTS.
THE E. I. R. TOOK --
I THINK A VERY IMPORTANT
THOROUGH AND CONSERVATIVE
APPROACH TO LOOKING AT NOT ONLY
WHAT.
THE PROJECT SPONSORS INFORMATION
SHOWED THAT THE RECHARGE WAIT
WOULD BE THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
ACRE FEET PER YEAR.
BUT ALSO LOOKED AT SIXTEEN
THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER YEAR WHAT
IF IT WAS HALF THAT.
AND WHAT IF IT WAS ONLY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER YEAR.
IT IS DIFFICULT --
TO HERE A CONTINUING REFERENCE
TO THE VERY EARLY STUDIES THAT
USGS DID THAT LANDED ON THE
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRE FEET PER YEAR.
WHEN THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH MORE
SITE SPECIFIC AND DETAILED
INFORMATION AVAILABLE DONE UNDER
THIS --
PROJECTS STUDIES SEVERAL YEARS
OF SITE SPECIFIC GROUNDWATER
MONEY MONITORING.
WELL MONITORING TO GET REAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LOCALITY.
A COMPLETELY NEW GROUNDWATER
MODEL TO UPDATE AND HELP PROVIDE
A MUCH MORE SOPHISTICATED
ANSWER.
ALL OF THIS AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE E. AYE OUR PROCESS FOR
CRITIQUE AND REVIEW --
SO THE E. AYE ARE WITH AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION TRIED TO
LOOK AT SEVERAL SCENARIOS OF
WHAT IF THERE IS A A DIFFERENT
RECHARGE RATE [inaudible]
AND MITIGATED FOR THOSE THAT
IMPACTS AND A PERSON SPOKE
EARLIER AND SAID YOU KNOW THE
ISSUE IS GROUNDWATER PUMPING
WILL DRAW DOWN THE GROUNDWATER
AND THAT IS THE CHIEF.
AGENT OF IMPACT INTO GROUNDWATER
PUMPING SCENARIO SO.
WE TOOK A LOOK AT UNDER ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT A RECHARGE
SCENARIOS THE FIVE THOUSAND THE
SIXTEEN THOUSAND AND THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
WHAT WOULD THE LEVEL OF DRAWDOWN
BE?
AND WE FOUND THAT AT THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
RECHARGE ASSUMPTION THAT THE
PROJECT SPONSOR BELIEVES IS
CORRECT.
THE DRAWDOWN WOULD NOT EXCEED
MORE THAN EIGHTY FEET OVER THE
LIFE OF THE PROJECT AND THAT
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE SIGNIFICANT
EFFECT.
SO THE COUNTY CAME IN AND UNDER
THERE ARE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ORDINANCE IN AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION SORT OF
TOOK THE DEBATE OVER THE
RECHARGE IT OF FACTOR.
OFF THE TABLE AND JUST SAID
WE'RE GOING TO SET A FLOOR.
THAT YOU CANNOT DRAW THE WATER
TABLE DOWN MORE THAN EIGHTY
FEET.
AND IF IF YOUR RECHARGE RATE
WORKS OUT THEN YOU'LL GET THE
YIELD YOU THINK AND IF IT
DOESN'T YOU'LL GET LESS AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE BOTTOM
LINE WE'RE GOING TO PROTECT THE
RESOURCES.
BY JUST SETTING A PHYSICAL FLOOR
ON HOW MUCH YOU WILL BE ALLOWED
TO DRAW DOWN UNDER OUR
MANAGEMENT AND A PROGRAM FOR
YOUR PROJECT AND WE WILL MONITOR
THAT AND WE WILL --
HAVE THE AUTHORITY WHICH IS IN
THE PLAN. TO TELL YOU TO STOP
PUMPING SHOULD YOU EXCEED ANY OF
OUR PARAMETERS INCLUDING THE
FLOOR DRAWDOWN.
SO I JUST THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
THAT'S REALLY MY MOST IMPORTANT
POINT.
UP FOR THAT DEBATE AROUND THE
RECHARGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS VERY QUICKLY ADAM CAN
UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES.
WANNA MAKE JUST A COUPLE QUICK
POINTS -- WE
UNDERSTAND THERE IS OPPOSITION
AND SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS PROJECT THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE HERE TO TAKE A POSITION ON
WHAT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
THE ADDITIONAL LAYER OF OF
APPROVAL THAT WOULD BE CREATED
BY THIS BILL THE PRESIDENT THAT
THAT SETS --
IF THERE ARE ISSUES WITH THE
SEQUEL PROCESS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK ON
THOSE WITH WITH BOTH AUTHORS BUT
AMENDING A BILL THIS LATE IN THE
SESSION THAT.
THAT UNDERMINED SEE QUIRK --
IS IS NOT THE RIGHT APPROACH SO
WE WOULD ASK FOR A NOBLE THING.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
PHIL MC ON THE ADVOCACY DIRECTOR
FOR THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION MANY KNOWN
AS BEST FED.
OR GRASSROOTS ALLIANCE OF OVER A
HUNDRED SEVENTY BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING OVER
THREE HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS WHO EMPLOY JUST ABOUT
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION POLICE
TO RALLY COUNTY.
AND WE ASK YOUR COMMENTS TO BE
BRIEF OUT OF GET HERE THIS
EVENING JUST EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT AND WAS ONCE A THANK YOU
ALBUMS ARE OPPOSITION OPPOSITION
OPPOSITE.
WHO DON'T KILL ME?
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT
LOSS ON BEHALF OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY --
LIKE OPERA WE ARE NOT HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THIS SPECIFIC PROJECT
--
THAT VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT --
WITH WITH SEQUEL AND THE WHOLE
PROCESS THAT WATER AGENCIES --
AND AND OTHER AGENCIES TO THE
SECRET PROCESS MIGHT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A IN THE FUTURE SO THAT
THOSE ARE CONCERNS THANK YOU.
MISTER SPEAKER WHEN NAME IS AYE
TERRY FOREMAN I'M --
A SENIOR HAIDAR GEOLOGIST THAT
DID THE WORK FOR THE KIDDIES
PROJECT.
AND JUST A COUPLE QUICK ISSUES
ARE ONE THE RECHARGE RATE.
AS OUR AYE DOWN THIS IS SAID
THAT AT THE TIME FOR A
REPRESENTATIVES TO STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR AFFILIATION AND
POSITION.
I'VE BEEN ALLOWING QUICK --
PERHAPS ONE OR TWO SENTENCES IF
YOU CAN MAKE A POINT.
OKAY WELL OF ONE IS THE THE
RECHARGE RATE THAT WAS A
REFERENCE WITH RESPECT TO THE
USGS WAS BASED ON BASICALLY A
GRAPHICAL TECHNIQUE.
DEVELOPED IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
HUNDREDS.
ARE WE ONE SENTENCE.
SO IT'S NOT VALID BANK IS IN THE
FOR THANK YOU. TWO GERMAN
PROCESO DE OF THEM HALF THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITHOUT MY COLLEAGUES
GOT WET IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY NAME
IS DIANE DEFELICE AND I AM ONE
OF THE ATTORNEYS FOR KIDDIES I
WILL BE BRIEF.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
SENATOR ROTHMAN AND FRIEDMAN I
DO NOT WANT TO PREVENT THE
ACTUAL PUMPING BUT I THINK BUT
IF YOU LOOK AT THE COMPOSITION
OF THE PEOPLE IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL THEY WERE ACTUALLY THE
MAJORITY OF WHICH HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
AT THE ORIGINAL SEQUEL PROCESS
AND ACTUALLY LITIGATED THANKS SO
OUR CONCERN IS THAT THIS IS A RE
OPENING OF A PROCESS THAT WAS
CONCLUDED [inaudible]
YOUR POINTS [inaudible]
IS ACKNOWLEDGED.
HELLO I'M MILES KENNY --
GEOLOGIST CHO KENNY GEOSCIENCE
AND MY COMPANY HAVE BEEN WORKING
FOR COULD IS ON THE PROJECT
SINCE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE DOING THEIR GEOLOGY.
AND I OPPOSE THE BILL S. B.
TONY.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CATATONIA AROUND WITH
THE CITY COUNCIL LABORERS IN
OPPOSITION TO TO CONCERNS ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT THIS WOULD SET FOR
OTHER PROJECTS SEPARATISTS
EQUIPPED THINK YOU.
SHARE MEMBERS STARSKY WAS ON
BEHALF ADMISSIBLE WATER DISTRICT
OF ORANGE COUNTY AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
OF ORANGE COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR OF MEMBERS SEVENTY
BETH WENT THIS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
THE CALIFORNIANS FROM
OPPOSITION.
MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
EVENING ROSANNA CARAVAGGIO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION IN THE
GROUNDWATER RESOURCES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA BOTH
IN OPPOSITION OBVIOUSLY THOSE
ARE GROUND WATER AREA
ASSOCIATIONS THAT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT OUR GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT.
SUPPORTED SIGMA AND ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE KIDDIES
PROJECT AND OPPOSED TO THROWING
ADDITIONAL REVIEW ON AT THIS
LATE HOUR IN ADDITION TO THAT I
AM ALSO REPRESENTING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THOUGH
TIE WATER DISTRICT.
IN THE MISSION SPRINGS WATER
DISTRICT THAT ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF SETTING
ADDITIONAL REVIEW AT THIS LATE
HOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE --
COMMITTEE I I JUST WANTED.
TO ADD TO THE RECORD IN THAT --
I HAD MET WITH THE THE SPEAKERS
STAFF WAS SPEAKER HAS GONE ON
RECORD IN OPPOSING THE PROJECT
--
LAST YEAR GOVERNOR BROWN SENT A
LETTER IN SUPPORT OF AB --
ONE THOUSAND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN SPELL WHICH WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO THIS
BILL -- AND
ALSO WE HAVE RECEIVED LETTERS
FROM.
THE TEN A GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
SPECIFICALLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- AS
WELL AS FROM UNITED STATES
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN
SPECIFICALLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
WITH THAT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MR TELL.
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER I JUST A
QUICK QUESTION FOR THE
OPPOSITION AND HOW MUCH IS THE
PROJECT AT A COST AND HOW IT'S
GOING TO BE FINANCE AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT FOR THE PAST
TWENTY PLUS YEARS.
THE PROJECT HASN'T REALLY PROFIT
IT -- TO
MENTION AND IN FACT IT'S INCUR A
QUITE THAT A SUBSTANTIAL LOSSES.
IF NEITHER ONE OF US REPRESENT
THE KIDDIES COMPANY THAT WE
CAN'T IT TO HAVE.
PARDON NOBODY KNOWS.
THE QUESTION IS HOW MUCH ANYONE
ME TO ANSWER HOW MUCH THE
PROJECT IS GOING TO COST.
I I AM IF THERE'S NO WITNESS
SINCE I MEAN I I DON'T THINK
YOUR BILL --
CALLS FOR THE EVALUATION OF THE
PROJECT YOUR BILL CALLS FOR THE
THE RED OF YOU BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE IN HIGH
ATLANTIC MISSION HAS HIS FEAR I
HAVE NO IDEA HOW MUCH PROJECT
WHICH IS THE REASON I THE
QUESTION WAS POSED TO THE
OPPOSITION.
ITS WE FIND OUT JUST WITHDRAW
THAT QUESTION IF ANYONE KNOWS.
SO IT APPEARS NEED NO ONE KNOWS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SHALL HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
I'M I JUST THEIR READ SEVERAL
ARTICLES THAT THAT.
IT DESCRIBES SOME ISSUES WITH
THE THE PROJECT.
AND A AND I THINK ANY TIME WE
WANT.
TO YOU KNOW PLAY WITH THE ECO
SYSTEM IN THE MOJAVE DESERT I
THINK WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL.
CEO ON SO DO YOU THE BUREAU
POINT BEING THAT I THINK --
WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC LAND I
THINK IT'S AN MAKE SENSE FOR US
TO HAVE THE STATE INVOLVED IN
THAT PROCESS?
WITHOUT AYE I ACTUALLY WANT TO
MOVE THE BILL.
I JUST MADE AND SECOND.
ANY FOR THE MISTER ACOSTA YEAH I
JUST BURKE BRIEFLY FOR THE A
DEPOSITION SO.
JUST MAKE SURE WE'RE CLEAR US
THIS IS GONE THROUGH A COMPLETE
SECRET PROCESS A VERY LONG --
ARDUOUS PROCESS THAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE
TRIED TO WORK ON AMENDMENTS AND
THINGS TO IMPROVE THE PROCESS
HOW LONG WAS THE OVERALL.
DOOR TO DOOR SEEKING PROCESS.
WITH THE TECHNICAL WORK WENT ON
FOR SEVERAL YEARS BEFORE WE
STARTED THE OFFICIAL PROCESS BUT
WE BEGAN WITH THE NOTE THE
OFFICIAL NOTICE OF PREPARATION
TWO THOUSAND TEN AND WE WERE
CERTIFYING TWO YEARS LATER.
GRETA THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
FORM. TWENTY ONE TOP OF MS
MELENDEZ.
THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS AN
INTERESTING CONVERSATION AT THIS
HOUR OF THE DAY I MUST TELL YOU
--
I AM JUST CURIOUS IF --
MAYBE THE HYDROLOGISTS
GEOLOGISTS SOMEBODY CAN ANSWER
THE QUESTION OF WHY.
WE ARE GOING TO WANT TO TAKE
WATER FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AFFECT THE WATER SUPPLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHICH
ULTIMATELY WILL HAVE AN EFFECT.
ON THE SUPPLY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I'M JUST WONDERING
THE THOUGHT PROCESS BEHIND US
[inaudible]
WELL.
I'M NOT THE HYDRO GEOLOGIST BUT
I WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT WE
LOOK AT THE CONTEXT OF THE ISSUE
OF STATE WATER PLANNING IN THE
CALIFORNIA WATER ACTION PLAN.
WHICH ASKS FOR REDUCE DEPENDENCE
IN NORTHERN ON THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CENTRAL DELTA.
AND SO THAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
LOOK FOR REGIONAL SOLUTIONS --
TIP TO BOTH REDUCE DEPENDENCE ON
THE SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
AS WELL AS THE COLORADO RIVER.
SO THIS IS WITHIN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
REGION AS A CONTRIBUTION TO
SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE TO COME UP
TO BE TO BE FOUND FOR IT SUPPLY
RELIABILITY AND ADDITIONAL
SUPPLY.
SO IT DID FURTHER STATE
INTERESTS.
IN IN TRYING TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OTHER COMMENTS.
SENATOR ROTH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN WHICH I CLOSE.
WELL I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF THE POINTS ONE OF THE
POINTS THAT WAS MADE BY SEVERAL
OF THE UMPS PRESENTERS AND
OPPOSITION HAD TO DO WITH
PRECEDENT AND YOU KNOW.
WHILE I AM NOT AN ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWYER I'M A LAWYER IN SO I
TRULY VALUE THE CONCEPT OF
PRECEDENT.
BOTH IN THE LEGAL CONTEXT AND
OTHERWISE.
IT'S CERTAINLY IMPORTANT AND IT
WORKS WHEN THE PLAYING FIELD IS
LEVEL WHEN THE RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT ARE FOLLOWED.
IN WHEN THE PUBLIC HAS A HIGH
DEGREE OF CONFIDENCE IN THE
PROCESS AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT
DOES NOT SEEM TO BE THE CASE
HERE.
OTHER WERE ORIGINALLY ISSUES
WITH REGARD IN SAM DID YOU KNOW
COUNTY -- AT
THE BOARD LEVEL WITH RESPECT TO
THE SELECTION OF THE LEAD
AGENCY.
I WON'T DON'T NEED TO GO INTO
THOSE I DIDN'T SELECT THE AGENCY
THE ULTIMATELY THE BOARD DID
SELECT.
OF THE WATER COMPANY IS A LEAD
AGENCYI ALSO DON'T KNOW WHY.
I MEAN THIS IS SCIENCE I DON'T
KNOW WHY THE CONFLICTS IN THE
SCIENCE IN AN INCORRECT
SURROUNDING THIS PROJECT WERE
NOT RESOLVED AT SOME POINT IN
TIME.
BUT I KNOW THAT THEY WERE NOT
AND AS RECENTLY AS IN APRIL.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A REPORT
IN THE JOURNAL OF ENVIRONMENTAL
FORENSICS HAVING TO DO WITH THIS
PROJECT THAT.
QUESTION SOME OF THE DATA
ASSOCIATED WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT.
SO THE CONFLICTS IN SCIENCE OR
WHAT FRANKLY DROVE ME TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE I TYPICALLY LABOR
WANTS TO BUILD A PIPELINE
WORKERS WANT JOBS AND DOWN WHERE
I COME FROM AGENCIES WHAT WATER.
AND I WANT ALL THOSE THINGS TOO
BUT I WANT THEM IN ASSISTING
NOBLE WAY.
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE
CAN'T DETERMINE WHAT TO DO WITH
THE RECHARGE RATE OF THIS BASIN%
IS AND THE SCIENTISTS ALL AGREE.
AND WE CAN'T DETERMINE WHAT THE
DISCHARGE RATE COULD POSSIBLY BE
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN A
SUSTAINABLE BASIS THIS AQUIFER
UNDER A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
PART.
OF OUR STATE FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME BECAUSE THE AGENCIES THAT
WILL TAKE THIS WATER.
THROUGH THE PIPELINE WE'RE GOING
TO SOME OF THEM ANYWAY HERE
GOING TO BE USING IT TO ENTITLE
PROJECTS.
AND HOOK UP WATER METERS AND IF
YOU BUILD A HOUSE AND YOU HOOK
UP A WATER METER AND YOU
PROMISED THE RESIDENTS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET WATER.
THEN THE SOURCE OF THE WATER
NEEDS TO BE SUSTAINABLE.
SO HAVING SAID ALL THAT I WILL
ALSO SAY IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
DURING THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
PROCESS.
IN COURT THE SCIENCE WAS NOT
LITIGATED.
THE SELECTION OF THE LEAD AGENCY
WAS ONE OF THE ISSUES THERE WERE
SEVERAL OTHER ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE PROCEDURAL ISSUES THAT
WERE LITIGATED BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING.
THAT THE SCIENCE ITSELF WAS NOT
LITIGATED IN COURT THERE WAS NO
DETERMINATION AND LITIGATION
OVER WHICH REPORT --
SHOULD BE RELIED ON AND WHY
OTHERS SHOULD NOT AT LEAST
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
E. AYE OUR PROCESS.
OTHERS CAN CORRECT ME BUT
WHETHER WAS YOUR WASN'T THE FACT
REMAINS.
THAT WE HAVE SCIENTISTS THAT
APPARENTLY DISAGREE.
AND TO MAKE AN ERROR ON THIS. TO
MAKE AN AIR ON THIS IF WE GET IT
WRONG.
WHO WILL BE RESPONSIBLE?
FOR SO I SAY HIT THE PAUSE
BUTTON.
TAKE A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
HOWEVER SHORT FIGURE OUT THIS
SCIENCE RECONCILE THE SCIENCE
DETERMINE A DISCHARGE RATE IN A
RESEARCH RESEARCH RECHARGE RATE
IT'S REASONABLE FOR THIS
AQUIFER.
AND THEN MOVE FORWARD I AM NOT
OPPOSED TO PUMPING WATER OUT OF
THE AQUIFER.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE DO IT
RIGHT AND WE DO IT IN A
SUSTAINABLE WAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ACCU.
I THINK THE SENATOR --
HE VERY ELOQUENTLY STATED I
THINK EVERYTHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE SAID [inaudible]
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND SO --
I WHY I JUST WANT --
TO A CONFIRMED A SENATOR THAT --
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT A VOTE ON
THE PROJECT ITSELF BUT THIS IS A
A A A PROJECT A VOTE FOR
ADDITIONAL REVIEW TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE FULLY UNDERSTAND THE THE
IMPACTS OF THE WATER TRANSFER ON
THE STATE'S NATURAL AND CULTURAL
RESOURCES CORRECTING FUTURE AND
SO -- WITH
THAT UNDERSTANDING --
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS A DO
PASS --
MOTIONS WERE MADE AND SECONDED
ADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM ONE SP ONE TWENTY BY
SENATOR ROTH THE MOTION IS TO
PASS.
MEMBERS WE OUGHT TO TREAT AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NOT VOTING.
CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
LINDA'S NOT VOTING RAYOS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE [inaudible]
STONE I SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT LAST BUT NOT LEAST TO
SOMEONE OR CHIU.
GETTING TO COLLEAGUES MY HOPE IS
TO FINISH DECIDED BEFORE
EVERYONE CLEARS THE ROOM.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE AS A
CLEAN UP BILL TO A PRIOR TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE BILL --
GOVERNING PUBLIC TRUST LANDS IN
SAN FRANCISCO IT SPECIFICALLY
DEVELOPMENT ROUND SEE WELL LOTS
OF OUR BILL WOULD ALLOW A FORMER
PARKING LOT TO BE DEVELOPED IN
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WITH A CHILD CARE CENTER ARE AND
SPECIFICALLY ALLOW THAT THE
DEVELOP THE DEFINITION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INCLUDE
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING OF
210020% OF AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
HAS WALLS CLARIFY THAT
DEVELOPMENT CAN INCLUDE OTHER
USES PROVIDED THEY BENEFIT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ARE AND ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
PUBLIC TRUST AND BURDEN ACT.
OUR CITY LIKE MANY ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF BOTH BEFORE
HOUSING IN CHILDCARE FACILITIES
AND WITH ME.
I HAVE REPRESENTATIVE FROM CITY
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS MISTER
CHAIR YOU I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
SUPPORT SUPPORT HERE'S A FEW.
QUICKEN EFFECTIVE THANK YOU WE
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
AFTER.
AND ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN TAKE THAT
AS A CLOSE MOTIONS BEEN MADE BY
MR FLOOR SECOND BY MISTER COSTA
MADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM THREE AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU THE MOTION
IS THATSENATE AMENDED
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN.
BROUGHT SEARCHING AYE MATTEUCCI
AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE CHAU
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I'M LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE REALLY RAYOS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE.
TEN ZERO ALRIGHT THAT BILL IS
OUT.
OF WE HAVE --
THIS SEVERAL WHITE HOUSE HE'S --
S. B. ONE SIX EIGHT ON HALL.
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL.
I AM TOO S. B. ONE SIXTY EIGHT
BY MEMBER Y. KASKI THE MOTION IS
TO PASS CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO
TWO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS OF LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY AYE AYE
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ. SEVEN TWO
SEVEN TO THE BILL ITSELF.
WE ARE ADJOURNED